– Hast du das grade gehört?
– Was denn?
– Was denn? Na, dass die Chefin mich
grade beschimpft hat!
Vor den anderen Kollegen!
Obwohl ich manchmal Fehler mache,
kann sie so nicht mit mir sprechen.
– Ja, stimmt. Das war respektlos.
Aber sie ist die Chefin.
– Jetzt hör aber auf! Ich sage dir,
ich akzeptiere das nicht länger.
Was fällt der eigentlich ein?
Okay, sie ist meine Chefin.
Trotzdem kann sie doch
normal mit mir sprechen.
Mit Herrn Müller hat es
solche Probleme nie gegeben,
obwohl er der Chef war! Aber diese Frauen!
– Na ja …
– Was denn sonst? Männer gehen arbeiten.
Frauen machen den Haushalt.
Dafür gibt es gute Gründe! Dann macht
jeder, was er am besten kann.
– Jetzt mal langsam.
Ich seh das ganz anders.
Meine Tochter Selma arbeitet
und möchte bald studieren.
Und ich bin sehr stolz auf sie.
– Ich rede ja gar nicht von deiner Tochter.
Gegen die hab ich ja gar nix.
Aber so eine Situation wie grade wär mit dem
letzten Chef nicht passiert.
Der war total anders!
Ibrahim! Ibrahim! Ibrahim! Hey!
Ja? Ja, ich brauch bitte
einen Krankenwagen.
’n Kollege von mir ist grad umgekippt.
Ich weiß nicht …